[Music]
so in rare case news that's Joe why
submit it by hello hello hello hello
hello hello doctors just discovered that
an eleven year old girl was born with
genes that came mostly and that came
almost entirely from her father she's
had her by yourself holy [ __ ] that's
Isaac with tooth we don't 9950 knew it
how does that happen it's not
fifty-fifty usually it's 50 feet it is
usually but how did they find that even
oh did she have a [ __ ] beard and [ __ ]
well she had a dick the way they found
out is because her so when she was nine
years old she was deaf right and so her
parents wanted to find out why she was
deaf cuz her dad was deaf too so then
they did a genetics test uncle Uncle
Jimmy was deaf and then they revealed
that genetics test revealed that she had
two identical copies of a very rare gene
and so at first the scientists thought
like damn this girl has some bad luck
she caught this super rare gene one from
each parent but it was meant to be yeah
but then it turns out that that gene was
not from her mother it was there were
both copies who were from her father's
Niki I can already hear the arguments
that that wives having like daughter
can't you got it from your dad and the
daughter just like Savage just like your
father
I'm done did not matter what I had to
say yeah so then they found out this yet
but then once they dig a little once
they've dug a little deeper they found
out that that wasn't the only gene that
she got twice from her father it was it
was a lot of her genes so this thing is
known as a genetic mosaic which shows a
variation in different tissues so only
about 7% of her blood cells show any
maternal genes so his sperm was that
strong no his genes yes same thing right
well I don't know if it's strong is that
it it incest rated the
the ovaries and then it took over its
DNA yeah so about 74 percent of the
cells in her saliva had only paternal
genes
that's crazy and then so apparently here
they're saying that there have been only
about 25 people in the world that have
been reported of this genetic syndrome
they have all been girls but this girl
who's now 11 seems to be the first to
not have cancer
oh they all have casual cancer because
these girls are getting double the
amount of cancer genes from the other
because usually when you get together
it's supposed to cancel or randomize
right well usually like you have a
dominant gene and fasters you the
healthy one if you have a recessive like
bad gene it gets covered by the dominant
good gene but then if you have both
recessive genes from the same parent
then it's gonna be activated yeah so
that's all these girls have cancer which
this one doesn't which is a weird you
sounds a little smarter that's like a
ramp
Geils lat oh I remember why I loved you
baby but then he remembers that you
didn't know there was an answer say the
full name of DNA what gets activated
baby what gets activated this penis oh
you really do problem dude
what keys well yeah so this is just
crazy so that never happened or like you
know almost never happened so like what
how many people are there like eight or
nine billion right
so if 25 people get this worldwide
that's [ __ ] less than it was that
homie that's way very very super super
super that's so [ __ ] minuscule
whenever people get these kind of things
I'm like BAM do lucky me [ __ ] like
people get these rare diseases or like
oh like they get a little [ __ ] cut
and then their whole arm has to be
amputated I'm like damn dude I'm [ __ ]
glad y'all I was that person I would
hate to know how rare it is yeah
like HPV everybody has it or something
yeah I want some I want some like
beneficial [ __ ] you know and it like I
want it to be like like oh what a
pleasant surprise
like I go I go for a check-up for the
eyes and [ __ ] in my [ __ ] optometrist
is like oh what a pleasant surprise
only one out of a thousand people have
this or one out a hundred thousand
people have this you have you have
[ __ ] sniper vision
what's that homie oh you have the
ability to [ __ ] scope in on on things
if you want to get doctor a Compton hood
dog [ __ ] what you go be you got this
type of vision cuz here's your medical
bill your doctor is also Mickey Mouse
would be [ __ ] cool though if I had to
get something that was really rare but
in the positive sense I think I would
want like regenerative genes oh you're
so fast what if it's something that
you've always had but you never knew
until they say it like you got [ __ ]
your nails grow fast dude super
when you're pregnant that happens my
nose would come out really fast extra
calcium or what yeah the pinedo the
prenatal stamp all of that stuff you
just have so much hormones oh yeah oh
yeah that's a shitty-ass superpower
right [ __ ] annoying dude [ __ ]
sheep quick quick every day just got a
funny clip your fingernails oh [ __ ]
that is annoying that'd be a fucked-up
one right I want the superpower of
what's it called going back in time like
like time time travel time jumpy that's
the one I want Bheema just back my heart
huh why just because I get to see [ __ ]
you know I mean or if I [ __ ] a bot
what's so boring I just go back you know
what I mean so like you know I want to
change yeah like I snap my ankles I
woulda just went back in time it's like
hey you [ __ ] tie your shoes you dumb
[ __ ] I start tying my shoes and then my
ankles will be fine or that every time I
went pick up the whole world have you
seen the movie Time Traveler's Wife yeah
I thought about that one immediately
you're asking for two things so you're
asking to time travel and you're asking
to alter whatever happens right well in
this movie the guy can only time-travel
that's it alternative being the
specifics I get the stuff that comes
along with it as well I'm not getting a
sandwich without the meat inside no
we're getting the whole shebang so I get
the travel in time and I could do what
the [ __ ] I want but you change
everything
oh no better for me I have my ankles no
but because you [ __ ] up your ankle
then you won the lottery but then now
that you fix your ankle buddy I'm not
gonna win the lottery you never know I
haven't won [ __ ] of my life with
anything like yeah what the [ __ ] did
that benefit dude after you broke your
ankle we stopped playing basketball
right now oh yeah I would look like this
two years of depression no you're my
ankle look at where you are now
no I would have been I would have been
in the NBA you wouldn't have met Mario
huh
that's nothing to do with the angle then
that happens I don't know it happens so
you rather loser it's not that I would
look I wouldn't know if I lost it
because I changed her you wouldn't know
you because you have memory
you wouldn't know that what are you
talking about our superpower where you
don't have memory of what you already
yeah if I change if I change it is what
it is
now I caught you memory of your time
travel with [ __ ] suck yeah that [ __ ]
would suck
I don't think breaking your ankle has
anything to do with getting Muriel
that's why I'm saying
same [ __ ] no he did cuz he says he would
go into the NBA
maybe we'll see oh you get something way
better than Mary yeah just kidding
there's nobody better than you but I
also said just kidding just as fast this
is the name of this company what else
would I do I'll change so many different
things breaking my ankle or my first
ankle and then I would changed breaking
my second Inc what about some regular
[ __ ] so like let's say there's like the
average human does this right and then
there's like people with superpowers
that are realistic like for example like
people an NBA they could have 44 foot
verticals or people with 2010 vision
like if there's a slightly leap powers
that you can have with it realistic I
would want the speed my people that can
hold your breath for five minutes you
know oh I want fast you train for that
No yeah fast ass [ __ ] hands Pat's
hands yeah like some light lightweight
boxer hands
yeah like Ryan Garcia [ __ ] oh [ __ ] would
you want you said you knew yeah I want
[ __ ] a cute like [ __ ] crazy ass
hearing so I can hear all that cheese
myth from all over what if it's far away
but you're tone deaf or you are you want
to build a hear like sound yeah but we
kept it in realism that has to be
realistic
oh yeah a realism mines and realism yeah
so if we're going back to that then then
I would have no no but I still want
really good here so just extra good
hearing yeah
so if the you're gonna have sensitive
ears because everyone's yelling all the
time don't tell me the bad what the [ __ ]
you did tell him the bad well I don't
know what
yeah what is the consequence probably be
in jail just punching everybody face no
cuz I don't see how I couldn't hurt you
you'd be like yo can you hand me the
keys no but you're like ah you still
look slow dreams okay fine you just want
to go to here sheer really good ask you
supposed to be a joke but you guys buy
two wheels so no I don't want that
anymore
we were talking realist I want the
ability to memorize things really really
well then no man that would be an
amazing actor I would be an amazing I
can speak so many different languages
there's a I think there's like a course
or something you get to have like super
expand your memory or make it I'm trying
to escape for my depression [ __ ] that
why trying to memorize life I guess [ __ ]
that's lock yeah but you can memorize
new things and then you forget the old
[ __ ] oh I really got to learn like a
third language than man oh shut the [ __ ]
up you said that's so many time oh that
would be mom [ __ ] dick you're a mom
do a better job there's people like that
that isn't your mom they're called
autistic savant oh yeah like uh there's
they have super powers like make you
like read a book and like look at the
page and forever remember that I know
someone like that you do yeah we know
someone like that who know oh you know
what autistics of what yeah what are you
talking about memorizing languages
they're like learning Alisa I don't even
want that I want what what my friend I
still have a friend back at home the
second is Corey this dude you know this
[ __ ] like I've legit he doesn't
[ __ ] cuz I've had classes with them
when we went to community calls together
same [ __ ] class I'm studying all
night right I get a [ __ ] like B on
this test this dude he runs into the
cluster [ __ ] I didn't [ __ ] study he
goes like this [ __ ] egg idaho me like
that yeah turtle cardona remember that
tall-ass Mexican for Alberto he's a
doctor now
Mexican Oh rarity dude rarity he's a
doctor now we were both in a medical
internship to have this same thing heal
but I don't [ __ ] study last night it
goes whole I just need ten minutes you
know I'm gonna do I'm we just walking
class late
studying all this [ __ ] in 10 minutes
because I got it and he comes in he get
to a yeah I'm like what become a doctor
yeah he's a doctor now you at the bar
bubble game when I first open the
support and then he quit after cuz I
don't think he liked me what no no no he
he he joined to support and he became a
doctor and it became a doctor iPod
became busy saving lives and [ __ ]
sometimes I feel like with me like with
memory and knowledge what happens is
it's like it's like this is this is the
memory right yeah you're supposed to go
past this wall it's supposed to be a net
your mind just steel-plate me - it goes
like what the [ __ ] is going on I'm like
you're gonna memorize this one phrase
today and I'm like I see it 30 times and
then Merida will call me right what are
you doing I'm like I don't know [ __ ]
such beings that gone past the plate
right so I know I have it in my pink and
then I gotta recall it and I'm like what
the [ __ ] is not even there what past the
steel plants on the outside there's like
a small person that grabbed it and threw
it back over the other so I know this no
I know this [ __ ] why do I know this not
me my [ __ ] goes over the plate and turns
into something else and you know what
[ __ ] was wild too though George said
he's every step within this plate it
also has a barrier of like letting
stupid [ __ ] going really well and
staying
dumb is details yes right or funny
stories things that happen I remember
that she's [ __ ] well yeah but
everything else that's important like I
don't know where the hospitals at why I
should tie my shoelace like this [ __ ] is
just [ __ ] god
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]